first off austin just how are you doing
you are having to live in the past with
more past still to relive while filming
the present there's a lot going on in
your life
yeah i mean bryce when when is there not
it feels like i mean i feel like i
always am talking to someone that's like
so how do you feel man and i'm
does it ever stop um
no no but yeah i mean i'm like watching
what happened six months in the past and
now i'm having to like film
my present it is um
i'm like take me back to winterhouse
well that says a lot without saying much
that you would rather live in that time
than all the time that's transpired
since
um
especially with what's happening right
now can we get into
the lindsay hubbard
of it all yeah let's rip the band-aid
off
who unfollowed who first
lindsay blocked me okay and then so when
you're blocked you just get
automatically taken off the file list so
you did not hit any buttons
well i would never i would never do that
you didn't hit any buttons on social
media you seemingly hit some buttons on
her person yeah
this all played out after your watch
robin's live appearance who is the
better cuddler of the two
sierra okay who is the better kisser oh
man sierra
listen who frightens your friends the
most
oh wow lindsay you won one
when did you realize that knight had
taken
the turn that it did
yeah honestly
bryce i
mean
i
i don't know i
so we went on like a commercial break or
whatever i i looked at lindsay and i was
like we're good i was like we're good
right you know we're good and she was
like we're good it's fine we're good
it's fine
and so i thought that at that point i
was like okay cool you know you know she
doesn't care that i said that you know
sierra's like a better kisser and i
certainly did not mean to like make
lindsay feel feel as badly as she's
making it seem that i did you know as if
i like as if like attacked her or like
you know kicked her dog or something
maybe lindsay just shouldn't uh she
shouldn't have been there that night
like i think that her emotions were
riding high too
because of the episode i i've never seen
her act like that before an episode
aired and she was just you know a little
like you know nervous
slash embarrassed probably of how things
played out a little bit right she was
like oh my god i literally
clapped and told you that i loved you
know things that like she didn't
remember until she kind of watched it
right the trailer dropped or what and
then
and then
you know her and i were talking and
yeah i
what was the conversation with her like
after the episode the next day like what
was the fallout from this was it an
immediate that night she went home and
blocked you or was there a conversation
so
afterwards i i guess that when we were
in the back and i was like all right you
know where we going out right like i
thought that everyone was good and she
was like i'm just gonna go home and then
i guess that's when it began to
circulate that like we had unfollowed
each other and i was like oh well that's
news to me
um
and i sent her a text you know i sent
her a text like lin's um our friendship
it is important to me um i hope that we
get a chance to speak in the future kind
of thing
and is that where it's been since that's
where it's been since
okay she
did an interview on her press run and i
want to get your response she said at
some point um
you know i i just i can't
like be okay with keeping
that kind of person in my life i don't
need to train a 34 year old man how to
be a good friend to me it's just like
not in the cards
how do i respond to that i mean
while keeping it all in check
it's like
i mean i don't agree with any of that um
i mean she is now you know dating
another person like i don't know why she
used to like
have me in in her life as much as she as
much as i know she has and had
um
you know it can be
an overbearing process right where it's
like okay i'm going to watch what
happens live and she's like okay well
like i'm you know going to come
and you're like
okay you know come on then linds but
like do not make this day like about you
and that's what she tried to do the
whole day the whole entire day from the
moment that i landed in new york she
tried to make the moment about her and
she was like oh my gosh have you seen
the episode oh my gosh you have to watch
it andy's going to give you a report i'm
like i'm good i'm good like i am all
good are you good
and then when we got there
you said andy asked her to sit sit in
the audience
and just the dramatics of it all like
she fell on the ground it was like
rolling around and was like ah they want
me to be in the audience i was like
linds this was your goal from from the
moment that you got here come on then
you know come on in the audience but i
was like it's not gonna change
my answers
and um i shouldn't have to train a 36
year old woman like how to not act and
watch what happens live
okay fair counterpoint but she hasn't
given you the space to have the moment
to move forward she pressed a hard pause
on this it sounds like yeah but look
dude
like
this what i'm saying like
you know
if i come into the city you know it it's
like
you know come over come over come over
come over come over and i'm like
lins i'm doing my own thing over here if
you'd like me for happy hour i'd love to
do that
and you know i'm like and aren't you are
you dating someone new like focus on
that focus on that i i'm like you know
doing good now life is is you know dandy
we don't have to
be in in
in constant contact like that i don't
know right well and i've seen some
speculation that people think she
and carl that's who she is seemingly
dating right now carl radke have
rekindled
but maybe it's not real maybe she's
trying to make you jealous do you have
any read on that
oh i don't know you know i just think
that her and carl are best friends and
have like they announced that they're
dating or something because they haven't
they haven't confirmed it they've been
very playful with it and that's why
there's a lot of room for interpretation
yeah um yeah i think that you know
they're best friends and that if they
did decide to date then um
that would probably be something that
everyone in their lives would probably
you know be happy with or or like agree
with
yeah i don't know them i don't know
who
she's dating or what
because she's not my friend anymore
remember right you yeah you have no way
of contacting her apparently um
where do you hope that friendship goes
do you hope it gets back to a place at
once was
do you have any hopes for it are you
leaving it be
yeah i mean look man i have so much
going on right now and there's a lot of
things happening and lindsay's
definitely has been a part of my life
um i i would certainly like to like mend
you know to mend but what would have to
happen at that point is that you know
it's like a different type of friendship
it's not the like waking each other up
in the morning you know with phone calls
kind of kind of friendship or like
coming to my watch what happens you know
like
or vice versa i think that the
friendship would just you know move in
like a different direction right because
it's gotten me in trouble in the past i
mean i like think that we're one way and
she thinks that we're another way and of
course it's my fault that i thought that
it was this way and i mean i'm just used
to getting blamed for all this stuff at
this at this point in time you know and
it's like
come on you know i didn't ask i didn't
ask for that
right i told you the moment that you
walked in the house and i made out with
like you know sierra you i applauded you
you set clear boundaries from the moment
she got in that house
thank you bryce there was there were no
blurred lines there was no confusion
about what was happening in vermont and
yeah so
i i definitely i i i would never say to
throw away a friendship unless it really
was like awful and toxic but if she
thinks that i'm not a good friend then
um i just hope that she comes around
essentially ball's in her court you have
to wait for her to make the move and
then you'll go from there and you know
what and that's fine because like i said
you know life is is moving forward down
here in charleston well and it's my
understanding that there's more life
that was maybe filmed to air in 2022
before we get
present-day charleston life that may
fill in some more gaps for us
yeah maybe uh the tangled web we weave
bryce
the tangled web that bravo weaves for
you i think yeah might be the better
i
do you have any recollection of the
new year's eve moment that she keeps
going back to new year's eve this year
we probably facetimed
15 different times i was like what are
your goals
i was shocked he goes lindsay i'm going
to date you this year
i'm glad you asked this because i forgot
about that yes yes i do
uh the year in question is
2019. 2020 i was in charleston i had my
hands full it was 2019 at msg i mean
i've come to msg like 2017 18 19 to go
see fish and she knows this
and you know
every year we've met up
like you know either beforehand or
afterwards of the show so i called her
in 2019
and you know things are not going
well with my you know now ex
and i was like my love life is in
shambles lens like maybe we should just
date like and if you haven't called up
like
you know your best friend at some point
and then like maybe we should just cut
cut through all the [ __ ] and maybe
the easier you know you and i just david
and that's what it was
and
i'm sure that i was like linds i love
you you know 2020 is the year awesome i
don't know and you know i'm not like you
know invalidating what
she said that i said
but it's like you know you look like a
friend and you're like hey if like you
know we're both 40 and single maybe we
should get together exactly that sort of
thing
oh all right we can move off of lindsay
and get into sierra now
[Laughter]
you
this
night one this hot tub works the magic
things got moving between the two of you
yeah i talked to sierra she said
this bled out into the real world too
you explored it a little bit after
filming wrapped but it you both decided
you weren't in the right
space to move on a relationship why was
that the case for you okay
um okay yeah i look
at that point in time
um as much as i hate to admit it you
know i just like wasn't fully over
and like at
a place to move on
like that and i was like i don't i don't
want to like let down
someone like her or like you know anyone
for that matter i don't want to be like
a half present you know boyfriend is it
something you would consider revisiting
in the future she said there are still
some feelings there
yeah look i mean
you know you never say never
and she
she's
you know wonderful and my headspace is
definitely in a different place than it
was then you know then it was fresher
now i've moved on i'm smelling you know
the roses and life is wonderful um
and
yeah you never say never sierra said she
had instant comfort and trust with you
because there were kind of stolen
moments off camera you know when cameras
are down where
you were able to
win her over yeah yeah there's like a
moment where it's like you know riding
in the car back from dinner and i was
like like and i was flirting with her at
dinner and leaving dinner and just like
you know very like subtle flirting and
then
i was like paige you go in that car
sierra you come in this car you two have
to be like a partner for once in your
life now come in this car and then we
were like you know singing like you know
karaoke songs and then that's the first
time that we kind of like held hands or
like you know touched hands a little bit
and so yeah yeah there were like you
know tiny moments that would have been
impossible to capture right that you can
only describe as like
like a feeling or like you know just
like you know you knew you know
right well even even moments that like
that could have been captured on camera
doesn't translate necessarily you don't
there's not feel a vision you know
right like
exactly bryce so it's like if you were
to watch that you probably would be like
they're not flirting
at all but for me like my heart was like
you know moving a little bit and it was
like yeah you like can't tell that like
that moment was palpable but it but it
was for me
you've said a few times in this
interview you take it you take it you
take it i feel like you get hit maybe
more than any man in the bravo universe
it's wild and the present moment have
you been able to unpack that why that is
because
having met you in person spent time with
you in real life i get it you're a very
charismatic person you have a certain
pull to you
and for some reason
that gets lost with the audience and
they just
i don't know
even even paige in the trailer
i know i know hold on let me get this
right
three girls fighting over austin kroll
[Applause]
just confused i was just sitting there
like really i was like this trailer is
so happy and fun and and light-hearted
and paige is the one to dog me and i was
like paige she was like i'm sorry and i
was like i don't
like you know and once again it's just
one of those things like you
compartmentalize and you pack
deep deep down
and that's going to translate to lots of
hours of therapy later on in life bryce
i don't know i don't i don't get it but
yeah it makes me laugh i mean i think
that like i'm pretty funny and great
rice but like you know i mean
i don't know it like angers women for
some reason i'm like i don't know why i
don't know why it's like
it'll be a probably a mystery to the day
you die
oh man and i don't know why it's such a
mystery
but um
i mean come on people
where are you at romantically right now
single
very ready to mingle cautiously mingling
not mingling at all
interesting um
cautiously mingling what what what is
cautiously mingling well i think full-on
mingling is like you're trying anything
you're going on dates left and right
cautiously you're being like thoughtful
with it you don't want to get stuck in
the consciously used to be in okay i'm
cautiously mingling
because i'm like austin you don't have
to date every single girl that you meet
and think are great and so i'm telling
myself that i don't have to do that i
don't have to
like
meet a girl that i like and get along
with and just like immediately date her
like i'm cautiously
moving down that there is the cloud of
your ex hanging over winter house and i
think
obviously we'll hang over at least the
start of southern charm with things that
have unfolded in real time
how do you feel about her these days are
you letting her live her life in just
separate
not part of your orbit
absolutely i mean isn't that the only
way to live you know yes that's how you
truly have to be like
you aren't a part of my life anymore
and you're gonna start a new family and
i wish you the best but like i don't
have to send like a gift basket like you
know and she shouldn't need that you
know from me right it's like no like we
didn't work out
moving on
um
you know of course i'm gonna see her
uh around town and and and on camera
and um i you know just like try to keep
it
you know let's see if she's capable of
keeping her you know insults to a
minimum